ladies and gentlemen there's a rap on  our day and a movie rap for Jennifer  Lawrence it was bittersweet to rap  Jennifer as mystique or Raven because I  think she's done the job of playing both  so well she's played Raven extremely  well and she's played mystique extremely  well when an actor gets to a place where  they feel like I've done everything I  could with this character as an artist  and as a writer and as somebody who's  her friend I felt like I understand that  I think I'll probably figure out what  Raven means to be in a few years but I'm  like looking back we all had a dinner  together  Jennifer's last night and you know we've  all become very close and there's always  been a great sort of family vibe on  x-men  it was quite poignant moment when we all  had dinner together and said farewell  [Music]